make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and um we're we're kind of in the
midst of of swords of x right this great
big huge 22 part series and one of the
things that i realized is that we never
really finished up
x-force right so we're gonna kind of run
through x-force really quick today
finish uh finish volume one and then uh
run through volume two
and then kind of continue on with swords
of x and with some of the series like uh
like wolverine for example wolverine
picks up with swords of vector this year
number six so when we get around to that
point we're just going to cover the
first six issues kind of call it a day
the whole idea here with this with with
this x-force comic is in the first
couple issues we had this scenario where
xavier was killed if you guys remember
that right xavier was taken out and it
was just by some individuals who managed
to infiltrate krakowa right so we're
kind of going a little far back right
we're going towards really the the end
of last year
uh in the beginning of this year right
so we're a little behind on this
i'd say we're probably about 10 months
behind on this the idea here is that
with these guys having breached the
notion behind this is that first they're
trying to figure out who these guys
belong to
and then two how they managed to get in
right it's kind of the continuing
talking point that's going on
in this little bit of a story but what
they end up doing is it's kind of
teleporting to a particular location at
least traveling there by way of one of
the cochon gates and then using a kind
of
mind sketch to a degree right which
basically takes sage with them sage of
course having what's essentially a
computer for a brain but it allows jean
grey to use your telepathy to kind of
analyze the the digital imprint that was
left there and to kind of figure out
kind of retrace these steps these guys
right to kind of follow them from
the point when they arrived on cocoa and
sort of fought like trace their steps
back right trace them back to
an eventual location now this ultimately
leads to the quiet council itself
meeting and then kind of discussing and
asking like what do we do here
that when it comes to to this strike
that was launched on the x-men that what
it looked like
is it was designed for the purpose of
accessing their computer systems and
basically acquiring or taking their
wealth right that seemed to be the goal
that was going on it seemed to more or
less be a heist
and that's kind of the question is why
would they launch that attack right like
why launch a heist against cricoa if
they're looking for information or
they're looking for resources whatever
the case happens to be now you had a lot
of pharmaceutical companies and a lot of
companies that were basically you know
kind of
you know owning governments essentially
that didn't really want to innovate
but with x-men popping up and the mutant
population creating pharmaceuticals that
were out
basically outshining anything that the
rest of the pharmaceutical companies in
the world could produce then in turn it
was like okay well let's try to sabotage
them or steal their technology right
and that's kind of where they are at the
moment it's kind of like okay these guys
are implementing a heist these guys are
trying to take what we have
what do we do here now xavier takes more
of an approach and saying that this is
something very similar to like the 12
labors of hercules right in the sense
that
we as the mutant population were
hercules in his early years meaning he
remained in hiding he didn't he was
afraid that people would try to come
after him or something along those lines
but when he
learned his true goal when he learned
his true purpose the son of zeus when he
learned what he was really about then in
turn he stepped out there into the world
and started undergoing the 12 laborers
and became the hercules that we know
today and xavier kind of takes that sort
of
scenario and applies it to themselves
and says for years and years and years
mutant kind was hiding we tried to stay
out of the limelight we tried to stay
away
from conflict we tried to move away from
those things it ultimately led to us
basically falling victim right we were
still being chased we were still being
hounded we just believed if we took the
peaceful approach
that we could somehow talk them into
believing in a better thing
but the the issue that you have here is
this is what's so interesting about
xavier's philosophy now the fact that
you don't believe that guns are okay
doesn't change the fact that a person
standing at you or standing in front of
you with a gun pointed to your face
right like they're gonna pull the
trigger so what are you gonna do the
days of trying to use words and talk
people into believing what you believe
and and to try to get them to understand
those days are gone
but now it's the x-men and really it's
the mutant population's job to either
drag humanity into the light or
leave humanity to its fate and just let
it suffer and conquer the world right
like just kind of take things over say
if you can't lead this world into a
better place then we will
and that's when he kind of says what we
need here is a team
that basically is going to serve as the
intelligence arm of the x-men with that
being the case they in turn say we're
going to reconstitute x-force and
x-force is going to basically be our cia
type team where they're going to be our
intelligence gathering apparatus the
first thing they do is they go to visit
forge right and then forge
again you know the guy who makes weapons
all kinds of armor and arms and armament
technology and and you know suits of
armor things like that and they
basically hit him up and say like we
need your help in developing weapons
what he's been doing here is he's been
taking krokoen
biology right so pieces of cocoa and
then basically hybridizing it which is
to say blending it with weapons
technology and what he's kind of done
here is he's actually created a kind of
device that bonds itself to the hand and
it can do any number of things it can
shoot energy
right it can it can turn itself into
like knives and stabbing weapons it's a
pretty powerful piece of technology the
other thing that was going on here
is that somehow and we don't really know
how but somehow
crocoa got its hands on adamantium in a
liquid state now the reason why i say
this is a big thing is because
it's very difficult to do the formula
for for adamantium isn't readily
available
somehow they managed to get their hands
on it but the idea is that if they ever
have to bring wolverine back they can
bond adamantium to his skeleton but this
is kind of a big deal because what it
also means
is that if there are other mutants out
there that have the ability to heal
right they have
healing factors you could bond
adamantium to them if they're willing to
undergo the process right so it's it's
actually a really awesome concept but
one of the first things they do is they
basically kind of have this this mission
they go on to a place called the point
or at least it's kind of a reference for
for where beast is operating out of but
they end up realizing that this location
this this kind of strike that's taking
place uh you know with regards to this
this heist is going on is a chance for
them to basically track these guys down
and find out why it is they track
cricoid why they attack
in the first place right and so what you
have here is basically a place where
you've got human allies right
they're basically called you know xavier
scholars so people who study
the the philosophies of xavier his views
and just kind of see what merit there is
but they're not enemies of the x-men
right they're kind of they're just
trying to understand the mutant
population
of course with this heist showing up and
with them having you know different coco
and you know bits of curcumin technology
at their disposal you end up having them
basically break into this place kind of
reach the
cohen gate and then shut the gate down
just as x-force is getting in and it
leads to domino basically kind of
bailing out right you know
her you know not really experiencing any
kind of a shut or anything like that but
with the gate shutting off the way that
it does
it cuts wolverine in half and it kills
quentin choir but the whole thing behind
this
is that with uh with the gate basically
shut down and no real means to access
this facility outside of getting into an
actual vessel and flying there right so
however long that happens to take
you end up having black tom cassidy hit
up by domino and then black tom cassidy
of course
talks to gateway and says like we need
you to teleport domino to a location now
the other part of this
and kind of a plot threat that's
beginning here and it's going to sort of
pick up later on
in the the next story that we do is that
domino's actually losing her power over
luck that's kind of the nature of domino
is that she can kind of bend luck to her
favor right so if domino's walking along
a whole bunch of slot machines her power
will tell her play that slot machine and
you'll win a million dollars right i
mean it won't say like you'll win a
million bucks but it'll just kind of
pull her towards that slot machine
and then she'll play it and then she'll
win like 50 million dollars in
progressive slots right which nobody
ever does but the other part of this is
that with her arriving there of course
she's also met by the arrival of forge
right forge is like look i'm not
like sitting this one out right like i
got all these arms and all this
technology and something like that i
want to destroy stuff man i'm tired of
sitting in the lab
that's basically the whole stance of the
whole stance of forge now once they get
in here you know kind of jumping back to
this this facility of course wolverine
being cut in half
immediately still starts killing people
but one of the guys is up turning their
gun on wolverine kind of spraying him
down
and the moment he kind of looks to be
dead right but then of course give gives
time for domino
alongside ford's to show up here right
now once these two show up domino uses
her technology which actually proves to
be highly effective
and then of course forge using his suit
and just kind of showing up here you got
a few guys who kind of show up try to
try to launch an attack they're all
subdued pretty quickly domino's a little
harsh on him but the funny thing about
this from from beast is he's like look
okay
these are the only guys that we have
that can give us information on the
original heist right they're the only
ones that all kind of work together or
at least know what was going on with
that heist
so uh don't kill them like you can be
the crap out of them if you want to
brutalize them all you want to but don't
kill them and when it looks like
domino's going to
that's when beat steps in and says you
have to stop the whole purpose of
x-force is to serve as an intelligence
gathering apparatus we can't gather
intelligence if the people with that
intelligence are dead
you have to save at least one of them
you know the other cool thing that kind
of happens here
is forge actually ends up grabbing
wolverine's pieces and just kind of
smashing them back together and it's
like nowhere yourself right like now
heal back up because we need you out
here and so what you end up getting here
is is once it's all kind of said and
done
right once you have uh the mission more
or less proving to be successful the
other guys have basically retreated
they've aborted you have domino who
walks up on one of the guys with the
intention of looking to kill him right
the whole kind of device she has on her
arm basically creates
you know something that looks like
wolverine's claws it's not really
adamantium but something similar to it a
pretty durable material and it looks
like she's going to kill him and that's
when beast is kind of like you have to
stop here right and it's a it's a truly
fearful thing one of the other things
that we kind of found out in their
various investigations
is that one of the things this kind of
secretive organization had been doing
was basically removing pieces of domino
right that's what was going on with her
in the first two
issues and why she looked so scarred
they had been cutting off pieces of her
and then basically seemingly to attach
them to like what looked like assassin
robots or something like that right it's
kind of hybrid beings but in her mind
she looks at this guy and says this
guy's probably not human he's probably
not actually human he's probably one of
those
weird looking hybrids that they cooked
up in a lab somewhere we can kill this
guy and it won't really matter but this
guy is like no i'm definitely human and
one of the laws of kakoa is you can't
kill humans unless your own personal
life is in danger this guy is begging
for his life and so ultimately
she basically ends up sparing this guy
and initially you have beast who does a
bit of an interrogation here kind of
asking a few questions and saying like
who are you working for what's the whole
deal the guy starts sobbing telling the
story about like his dog and how his
dogs at home somebody needs to go check
on him that kind of a thing
but the torture methods of of cocoa are
not inhumane but they are somewhat
brutal right depending on
on how you perceive it right where he
kind of spills this this story
to beast and says like we just get our
orders from the top right like we
this wasn't any kind of a political
maneuver it wasn't a political job it
wasn't like a hit job or anything it was
designed to be a heist the response of
beast is a one you guys killed xavier so
how much of a heist could it possibly be
and then two you attacked a political
nation that's new to the world
in the face of the world being afraid of
it how could this be anything but
political
intergene grey who uses her powers and
basically starts to
you know attack this guy's mind and
that's where that kind of violation
begins to come in right like reading
this guy's mind in a way where he can't
legitimately fight back but at the same
time he also kind of asked for it so
that's when we end up finding out that
this mysterious guy that we saw at the
end of like the first and second issues
is the guy this thief is basically
working for right that they get their
orders from this guy he doesn't know
their name
the whole the whole purpose was for them
to go into krakowa to steal some stuff
to go into that that you know facility
steal some stuff there and they were
gonna sell it to these guys right part
of it was
we're paying you for this heist and then
you're gonna bring these different you
know these goods and so on to us but
they don't know the guy's name right all
they know is he has like a peacock
tattoo and that's it they don't know his
name they don't know what his face looks
like or any of that stuff or they simply
just know this guy is there somewhere
but from here we pick up with the final
mission of x-force in this first part of
the story and we end up
joining in what's basically a place
called terra verde and terra verde is a
nation that's looking to sign a treaty
with
uh krakowa for you know in order to
access those various cocaine seeds that
xavier has at his disposal but the idea
behind terra verde and this is kind of
important here the idea behind tierra
verde is that they were at one point the
world leader in what was called
telephloronics and telephonics was
basically kind of it's kind of this
weird wonky word to describe the idea
of creating a means of healing people to
create what are essentially nanobots
right so super microscopic machines that
were not really machines but were
plant-based in origin and these could be
used for a number of healing you know
healing factors and different things
like that to heal injuries and so on the
problem with this is that while they
were leading the world with this kind of
research
it was still pretty far off from being
something that could one include human
trials and then two
be mass marketed and then controlled and
so on and so forth but the
relative early days of their experiments
relatively recently you suddenly had
xavier who popped up with curcumin seeds
on kakoa and so basically all this
technology
vanished right like any funding they had
just disappeared overnight but within
teraverti itself you also had a guy
named president como and this was a guy
who basically kind of stabilized the
region stabilize this country which had
been warring for quite some time and so
it was really pushing towards more of a
plant-based society but the funny thing
about this is that with this treaty
being signed
you end up having of course black tom
cassidy who attends with charles xavier
in order to keep him protected right
since blind tom cassidy can control the
earth and so you end up having these
guys who show up and start kind of
manifesting these tendrils of sorts and
immediately start going after president
coma and with that happening you have
black tom cassidy who kind of implements
his power that seems to kind of shut
these down when you have the attack
going after the president himself black
tom cassidy of course saves xavier is
also able to kind of
kind of stave off the attack from the uh
the invaders which largely happens off
panel we don't really see that all we
really get is the the statement of black
tom cassidy in the sense that like they
basically ran away right they seem to
get scared and just
and sort of flee but the responsive
beast is if these guys are going to be
brave enough to launch an attack against
the president as well as xavier at the
same time then why just run
right that doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense and so beats response that
you really tell sage
go back and pull up all the information
that you can and all the
camera feeds that you can of this whole
thing right like kokom
the president himself has gone through a
whole bunch of different attempts to
remove him from power over the years but
somehow this seems a little bit
different and so what you end up finding
out here is that the attack itself was
not designed to go after president cocom
it was designed to go after his son
which is the smartest move to make if
you're gonna try to
control the president take his son and
any president anybody who's worth any
worth of damn will do whatever it takes
to keep their kid alive right unless
their kids really just that far of a
lost cause
and so ultimately when he came out and
said he's not going to sign the treaty
in the aftermath of this incident the
immediate response of beasts and all
them is okay it's because they have a
son
it's because they took his son and
they're forcing his hand and so what you
end up getting is basically beast and
jean grey in them who show up on the
doorstep of president cocom
and don't really have any intent of
harming him instead gene reads his mind
and says okay
tell us everything you know what we end
up finding out is that these
weird-looking wonky guys of these
tendrils are basically telephonic
scientists who were taken over by their
own experiments now the indication here
seems to be that these experiments are
almost kind of like venom in nature in
the sense that somewhere along the line
they developed some kind of sentience
and then basically became hostile in and
of themselves they kind of became
parasitic and basically latched
themselves to these guys
the other part of this is that if these
beings really are operating in the realm
of self-preservation then it wouldn't be
that far
out of the realm of possibility to
create the argument that with research
drying up that there was no more
attempts by this group to
you know to create these guys more so
than that the research was probably
being killed off
and so it was these telephonics
basically being killed off themselves
this is really seeming more of an act of
self-preservation than anything else but
regardless of how you try to slice it
the response of beasts is
we have to go basically launch this
strike against these guys the other part
of this this is really more heavy-handed
by beast
is to say that in his mind
telephloronics are a massive
credible threat to the mutant population
and the reason for that is if
telephonics are a kind of organization
that exists out there and it bonds
itself to people then it can bond itself
to almost anything else
more so than that if it bonded itself to
these guys and they started evolving
over time
then what would happen if we had a
telephloronic who's powerful enough
to reach into the world and control it
then at that point you have a being that
could basically go after the mutant
population by targeting their own island
meaning humans or mutants would have to
like take to the skies in order to
escape you know the surface they could
never go back to the surface world again
but it basically creates a scenario
where the mutant population could
legitimately stand
on the realm of complete and total
eradication right because at that point
then suddenly this being could start
producing different kinds of pheromones
or producing different kinds of
substances
from plants that specifically target
mutants and then basically make the
entire atmosphere of the earth
poison for the mutant population and it
would kill him that's the kind of thing
that we're talking about here it's
far-fetched but the idea of beast is
it's not that far-fetched right that's
that's what he that's really his biggest
fear like this kind of of
hybrid uh fusion between these plants
and these humans also yeah these human
beings could lead to some
kind of future version of these you know
telephonic beings they could basically
turn the entire weapon or the entire
earth into a weapon
against the mutant population and then
wipe them out right the entire
population would go extinct and so the
response of beast is do what you have to
do right
we cannot leave behind any witnesses and
we can't leave these things behind
kill them all and and that's the crazy
thing is because the response of beasts
is they're not really human right when
when gene asks a question what about
what what happened to kill no human the
response of beast is they're not really
human beings in the first place not
anymore they're like omega sentinels
they're more machine than man
right twisted and evil consumed by the
dark side but that's basically what they
are right and so gene basically
eradicates these things using her powers
and then they basically start
going after and attempting to find the
son of president cocom and once they
locate his son they end up finding out
that he's a telephonic himself
and that he is one of the one of the
individuals out here who's trying to
bring down the trying to bring down his
father right
the whole thing was staged it was all
planned by him he staged his own
kidnapping to force his father's hand
the idea behind this is that it wasn't
really as though it was like an
acquisition of money or power or
anything like that i mean it was to a
degree
but the the whole stance of the
president's son is that with tara verde
being on the verge of telephone
telephonic breakthroughs that if they
had succeeded it would have been it
would have put them at the forefront of
everything right they would have been
like the the wakanda of the healing
world everybody would have come to them
right for the from this pharmaceutical
standpoint
everybody would have come to them and it
would have taken them from a small
little nation that barely just achieved
stability to being like the center of
the
of the pharmaceutical world the other
crazy thing that comes out of this is
that beast kind of looks at the
situation and says that had this
technology gotten out there right had
telephonics gotten out there that
humanity would have realized there was
an alternative to cocoa medicine
and that they would no longer recognize
mutant's sovereignty if that was the
case
then in turn it would have caused
massive problems for the mutant
population
and so in an act of maintaining the
mutant population stance
as to where they are in terms of
maintaining their power you end up
having beasts basically wipe this guy's
mind
like and not even in the sense of him
just like wiping his memories but in the
sense of him basically kind of
recoding the telephonic uh substance in
his body to essentially eat his mind
alive and all it does is just kind of
leave him in a feeble state right at
least
in a vegetative state and it leaves his
father there you know it's like your
son's here albeit you know beast
basically saying like which of these was
the two evils right to kill this guy's
son
or to tell him his son was a traitor
which of these were the two best
two right things to do keep in mind
xavier was behind this as well and
that's kind of the nature of these
things right it's what had to be done
in order for the mutant population to
maintain its role in in the world and
to achieve its level of power and so
what you end up finding out here is that
this kind of telephonic substance inside
the body of the president is actually
sentient right that he's wholly
telephonic not just in terms of it
impacting his body or anything but just
on the biological level it is
merged with him in its entirety he's not
just wielding it as a weapon right like
he is this and so basically it kind of
breaks down
and literally leaves the hospital room
and then reforms itself
okay so from here we jump to the next
part of the story and this is this is
one of the things about benjamin percy's
x-force run benjamin percy is a good
writer but the biggest issue with this
x-force run is it just kind of feels
like it's
all over the place the idea here is that
we kind of jump back a little bit there
are there were a couple things going on
with the idea of domino honestly in
order to keep things simple
we can largely skim over it basically
like domino ended up enlisting the help
of colossus who had kind of left
left cocoa in the x-men for the savage
land in the aftermath of everything that
was going on you know in the sense of
his attack when he was in
uh russia i think it wasn't helping to
liberate people you know the injuries he
the injuries he suffered they ended up
of course finding out that the reason
why domino's
portions of her skin were being removed
is that because this this kind of
secretive organization that existed out
there basically served the purpose of
trying to create more versions of her
for whatever their goals happened to be
ultimately colossus kind of jumped in
front of like a moving train which was
their base or at least part of their
base of operations where their research
was
the train was destroyed all the the
samples on the train were destroyed and
domino ended up dying and of course they
resurrected her from the dead and then
colossus went back to doing his thing
and that's basically it right that's
basically all that happened that little
segment by no means is
any of that overly important right and
it's kind of weird but the x-force team
is kind of sent on another mission by
beast but this was kind of a follow-up
to the events of terra verde where
basically this pterafloronic that had
escaped president
kokom's son you know kind of going out
and manifesting on his own has basically
taken
a taken over the country on its own
right taking over the country in its
entirety now the fact that beast was the
one who made that call and did those
things that kind of screwed up that
guy's mind and all that
leads him to kind of running this
mission on his own right so it's him and
he's the one basically talking to
quentin choir to uh to wolverine and to
domino now this is kind of a big deal
because the entire nature of
x-force because it is so clandestine
relies heavily on trust that you
trust the guy next to you to keep your
back and you trust that the people who
are giving your orders aren't sending
you into like a suiciding on a suicide
mission and they have trust in beast
that beast is not going to get them
killed but
beast is in a lot of ways trying to
cover his own tracks here that when he
kind of sends them in there that it's
like okay i need it i need to know
what's going on well i need to know
everything that's going on inside there
and i need you guys to meet with the
president and the problem with this is
that with president kocom he's dead
right like he was literally taken over
by these plans and kind of bonded to a
wall you know it's a pretty screwed up
way
the other thing here is that with these
you know with the whole country
basically being taken over
in such a rapid amount of time it shows
us one what these telephonics are
capable of in the sense that beast was
right with their ability to tap
into earth and then manipulate it for
their own ends and that two
they have no regards in killing people
like this this is basically a dead a
dead country
beast killed everybody here and beast is
kind of trying to keep things quiet the
other part of this
is that it's kind of formed its own kind
of society in a lot of ways and this is
like
its own kind of plant life you have what
looks like basically a kind of leopard
or a tiger or whatever it is they kind
of like manifest out of the ground
right and then just kind of starts going
after them sort of walks into the end of
the temple where all this seems to sort
of be emanating from which looks like
the base of operations for these guys
the other thing that kind of goes on
here is black tom cassidy
has had a kind of existential crisis
right he's trying to be a good guy
not been doing very good at it trying to
turn over a new new leaf turning to
alcohol in a lot of ways to kind of get
himself put together
beast ends up kind of enlisting his aid
and saying like we need you here and
with black tom being hungover
beast ends up just basically taking him
and saying like we're gonna get you
sober and we're gonna get you out there
into the field this is your lucky day
you want to be a hero go out there with
x-force and go be a hero right like go
fight the good fight
the other thing that goes on here is you
have quentin choir who tries to chime
into beat and telling him like this
whole nation
is a living organism now and has killed
everybody here and is taking us
out and it grabs quentin choir and then
snatches him off now once quentin choirs
pulled in
you end up having wolverine and you have
domino who basically follow him in there
and of course quentin choir just kind of
responds to them with like telekinetic
weapons and different things like that
but he's got like a bandana tied around
his head
right so he looks kind of cool but once
they're in here there's a couple things
that go
down one is that this plant life looks
like it's been growing for eons right
like it's been growing for centuries
that's kind of the statement that's
given uh it's wolverine who kind of
gives it so what it looks like is that
these things have been growing for quite
some time this kind of landscape's been
here for a while
there's some sort of of kind of toying
with the idea
that this is how the telephonics were
basically engineered by using organic
like living plant life that existed out
there in that temple
and then kind of bringing it to the
world and then trying to engineer it so
basically like they tapped into what
were basically
like evil plants for lack of a better
word and now they're pissed that kind of
seems to be the case the other part of
this
and something that i would say is
probably the most knowled or probably
the most reasonable
is that the plants really have existed
here for quite some time and in fact
benjamin percy basically tells us as
much but there was a kind of
balance of nature that existed here
right that you had the the plant life
that was there and presumably over time
it would feed on people but it was a
kind of
a kind of balance in this this sort of
ecosystem but that with beast basically
tapping into this well really not even
just beast beast and the attempts to
utilize telephonics you know for their
own purpose that they created a kind of
imbalance that with beats cracking the
code of the telephonics and then trying
to find a way to engineer it for his own
end
literally playing dr frankenstein with
this kind of plant life he didn't know
anything about but he shifted the
balance of power and that what it's done
is it's made the plant life more like
really kind of elevated it right so it's
kind of taken on the form and become
more human-like and elevated it above
its post right so
basically it's kind of achieved a new
level of power and so that means that
that's how it was able to kind of take
over the entirety of the nation and that
answers the question
why it never did that before presumably
because it never occurred to this plant
life or this plant life wasn't
previously capable of that but whatever
the case is
beast literally altered it in such a way
to where he changed its genetic
structure and made it something wholly
evil well
not really evil but something just
wholly twisted and kind of moved it up
along the food chain and so with that
being the case
you have wolverine and you have quentin
choir who are both snatched up right
they're both basically taken away and
what these telephonics are doing is
basically consuming humans right
consuming organic matter
and then like literally eating it for
you know and kind of forming their own
society in that way
it's kind of interesting here because
wolverine's one of the ones they take
they already took quentin choir they
already kind of
sacrificed and consumed him right so
he's kind of being converted basically
into plant life and wolverine's kind of
undergoing that conversion process
the the real kicker here is whether or
not wolverine's healing factor can
overcome that and it kind of seems like
to a degree it can
but it's not something that works
against his healing factor right it's
not considered to be a kind of
invasive you know pathogen that his
healing factor would immediately attack
right it's like a cold or a flu or
something along those lines what it does
is it modifies their body on the genetic
level and for the most part that kind of
seems to sort of operate under the
purview of his healing factor and his
healing factor just doesn't really seem
to notice it right and so
either that or his healing factor
doesn't know what to do with it so it
does nothing but whatever the case is
it basically points to the idea that
wolverine is susceptible to this and
could be taken over just like everybody
else now the other thing that goes on
here
is jean grey realizes what was happening
that with beast basically leaving her in
sage in the dark not really even telling
this mission was going on in the first
place but gina basically probed his mind
and realized what was happening and
that's when she shows up here and she's
like you basically lied to everybody you
engineer this whole circumstance one
just to see what could happen
two you're trying to find a way to bring
this place into krakowa to use it for
our own ends like you're making the
argument the ends justify the means but
the reality beast is that you killed a
whole country
you killed an entire nation of people so
yeah like
sure what they were doing would have put
kokoa at risk in terms of our place
and the political and social hierarchy
of the world right it would have
possibly slid us down the pole in terms
of our ability to
maintain our dominant place you know
with the various medicines and stuff
that we have but you sacrifice a whole
nation of people to do it and and we as
people
like we as mutants have to be better
than that we cannot adopt this
philosophy that the ends justify the
means but the reality
is that it does right the ends really do
justify the means because the states
that jeans seems to be taking here is
that if beast had done nothing and kind
of allowed things to unfold then mutants
then everything the mutant population
had worked for would have failed and her
desire to do the right thing she would
have killed their success
right and at the end of the day that
cannot be allowed to happen right that
cannot be allowed to take
place that mutants have struggled long
enough that because of her her caring
and her cold-hearted nature she'd killed
everything they worked for and at the
end of the day
beast is like no like we're not we're
not playing that game right we're not
doing that right i did what i did i make
no apologies for it and yes i sacrificed
a whole nation of people but what's this
nation of you know 100
000 people in comparison to the millions
of mutants that will be here
over time right through just procreation
and so on and the mutants who are here
right now right basically the argument
beast makes is our need is greater than
theirs and the experiment is worth the
loss right and it's a legitimate
statement and it's an accurate statement
to make right it is
it really is worth the loss and so
because of that of course again quentin
choir he's dead wolverine kind of ends
up popping up and manages to make some
measure of an attack but even then he
starts to
to be overcome by these vines again and
that's when you end up having jean grey
kind of working together alongside sage
with sage kind of analyzing this
taking the information of beast and
realizing how all this is how their how
their entire genetic structure for lack
of a better word how that works the
response of gene is we can combine our
powers right we can
basically use the power of sage like her
mind and we can use the the power of
gene herself to kind of anchor everybody
together and the power of black tom
cassidy to essentially introduce a kind
of virus into their genetic code
effectively they give the plant life
cancer
and break it down and kill the plant
life at a rapid state that's all it is
right just mutated cells right you know
free radicals right but in response to
all that with everything that's happened
and this whole conflict you know ending
pretty fast
jean grey quits right because her whole
stance is x-force is supposed to exist
on a basis of trust but wolverine kind
of calls her on it right and says like
you were never really meant for this
right like the nature of x-force isn't
to be
this kind of altruistic group that does
good things because it's the right thing
to do the whole purpose of x-force is to
be as bad as the bad guys right because
that's how you win you win by becoming
as bad as they
are that's just what you have to do in
order to win now there's no arguing that
point jean
is too kind for that and so she can't be
with x-force because she can't really do
what needs to be done
the other thing that kind of goes on
here is she's sharing a bath with
wolverine
[Laughter]
it's good to see that uh the whole the
whole kind of uh love triangle
between uh jean grey and cyclops and
wolverine is still there right that's a
cornerstone of their character but the
the whole thing about this is it kind of
switches over to a degree in that
in the aftermath of all this that you
kind of have autopsies that are done on
the various bodies that were taken and
what you end up finding out here
is that what these telephonics had done
was actually managed to achieve the
exact same process
as krakowen technology in the sense that
when you have dr reyes who goes to cut
one of them open
and perform a kind of autopsy this
smaller body jumps out cuts your throat
and takes off
the what telephloronics have managed to
do is find a way to resurrect themselves
that's basically what they what they've
done here right that
in the event that they're that the the
main person dies right so say you're
infected by one of these telephonics uh
you basically become holy that plant
life right you lose your own real
identity here but in the event that you
die
what would happen is you would basically
kind of reconstitute yourself
inside your own corpse and then emerge
at some future point in time right
almost like a like a butterfly out of a
cocoon except you know
not really pretty like like pretty ugly
and nasty looking uh but that's what
happens
across the board here right it's very
similar to the xenomorphs from the alien
stories but they kind of start popping
up
out of all these corpses right it's kind
of popping up all over the place and
that's when things start
you know sort of pop off because from
their perspective they do what is
inherently in their nature
which is to spread across krakowa right
so it's the events of beast kind of
getting continually worse now the other
part of this is you have
domino who shows up to colossus and for
the most part for the character of
colossus with him being out right with
him being in the savage land down in
antarctica and being out and away from
cocoa that he's at a place of peace
he's removed from all of this right he's
removed from
everything he wants to be left alone and
so when domino shows up and asks him to
come back his response is
no like i i began as a farmer i'm going
to stay here as a farmer i'm just going
to and to enjoy this time that i have
go away and leave me alone i don't want
to be part of this whole x-men thing
that you guys have anymore the problem
with this
is that as things begin to pop off in
krakowa the various madroxes that jamie
had
i'm sorry that colossus had on his farm
who were basically farm hands
immediately start bolting towards the
gate of kakoa and that's when colossus
realizes
something's going on here right and so
of course he basically you know
activates his osmium skin
and goes taking off towards the the
gates as well leaving what looks like
his girlfriend kayla behind or her
sister or something like that i don't
think we're really given a whole lot of
information about this character but he
basically leaves her behind
and when he gets in there everything's
popping off this sentient island is
literally going nuts right like these
little things they're like little evil
pixies right they're like running around
with these little guns they got little
knives stabbing the hell out of people
and these things are maybe like two feet
tall but they're causing all kinds of
havoc on this place right like just
little evil pixies just ripping the
whole place up now of course this leads
to black tom cassidy showing up to
xavier and basically saying like we're
locking you away right so it's like
taking the president to a bunker uh
while that's happening one of these
little guys manages to kind of sneak
away and basically accesses one of the
swords from swords of x right from
basically accesses the cerebral sword
and so he effectively takes off with it
and then from there like colossus shows
up helps to overcome this
great big huge thing kind of saves the
day and then leaves right it's just like
i'm done right you know and that's the
crazy thing is
you kind of have this this sort of
conversation between uh between you know
domino and colossus
where he's like after i'm done with this
like do not come back and find me
that's kind of thing they had a little
bit of a romance to a degree but now
he's done right he's done with her he's
on with the x-men the whole nine yards
you know and he's like do not come and
find me right like do not come back
leave me alone and so he basically just
ends up leaving right he just ends up
kind of going off and doing his own
thing
switch over to quentin choir right
quentin choir is kind of making out with
uh sophie from the stepford cuckoos it's
good to see that he got one of those
girls or the funny thing is as soon as
that happens he's immediately stabbed
and then he's knocked through the portal
by one of the guys
now here's the thing a lot of people who
are fans of quentin choir right like all
30 of them they'd probably be pretty
pissed off that quentin choirs being
killed
being killed and kind of throw away
thrown away like this honestly i'm a fan
of quentin choir but i'm biding my time
because here's the thing
i feel like quentin's gonna have this
ridiculously op moment right i feel like
it's kind of kind of slapping him around
a little bit and then just giving him
this ridiculously amazing moment later
on down the line because remember he's
an omega level telepath right he's not
easy pickens but when he's knocked
through here he's immediate
immediately met by the arrival of
mikhail rasputin right the brother of
colossus and we end up finding out that
the brother of colossus is the one
who's leading this whole secretive
organization or at least involved in
this whole secretive organization now
mikhail rasputin is strange
because marvel has never fully fleshed
out what his powers are we know that he
can kind of transmute matter on
different levels but it happens in
different ways right he can travel
through time and space or he can like
change
a person's body structure right to
change them into something else it's one
of these things where it's kind of like
matter manipulation but only as it
pertains to like another person's
physical body and like his ability to
move through time and space but it's one
of these things where mama kind of keeps
him in kind of this great area where
it's like could he become a reality
manipulator or is he kind of confined to
this thing we don't really know because
we don't really care because we've never
taken the time to tell you like that's
kind of what it is
that's kind of what it what's going on
with this character but regardless he
ends up dragging him into what looks
like the kremlin right so like the
capital of of uh the russian government
and that's when it kind of when you get
this this sort of switchover where the
main henchman right of this guy of you
know the the leader who was at one point
defeated by you know the
of the zeno group basically who was
defeated by mikhail rasputin is
basically brought back right he's kind
of resurrected he doesn't really matter
it's not really a major
talking point he's kind of enhanced a
little bit right like each time he dies
there's modifications that are made to
him to improve on the way
you know to improve on him so he doesn't
die that same way again or that he can
stand a better chance uh but as soon as
mikhail rasputin walks in here like one
he's been attending all these meetings
they
they've been holding this meeting from
mikhail rashford right so they kept it
hidden and then in turn
you also have like omega red who's on
kakoa as well right kind of a quick
little thing but like this this big
attack kind of happens this kind of big
assault happens between mikhail and this
henchman guy this human guy is overcome
pretty easily but the important thing
that kind of comes out of this
is that one mikhail rasputin turns into
stone and destroys him and then two
you have this conversation where uh
where where because it's mchale rasputin
and because the x-men learn about this
that beast goes after colossus again and
then brings colossus back to the island
but what's happened is beast seems to
have kind of told everybody what was
going on and that pisses off wolverine
who basically attacks beast and it's
just kind of like dude you dick
he chases everybody out of there and
they end up taking colossus to kind of a
sort of not really an interrogation
space kind of an interrogation space but
basically says like look we have some
questions that we need to ask you
about your brother mikhail and about
about everything you can tell us right
like what you can tell us about him his
involvement your familial ties what it
is that he's doing here
the important thing is that we kind of
get an answer from benjamin percy on
this that mchale rasputin basically
hands this weapon over to the head of
zeno and says look the time has come for
you guys to accept the way things are
for the longest time
you and the various organizations who
have existed out there the ones that
came before you have fought against
mutant kind on your own you fought
against the mutant population
by yourself but that doesn't work right
you've built me an army you've given me
everything that i needed but my
resources are also now
your resources if we are going to take
down the mutant population
we have to work together you have to
accept help from mutant kind and so what
this means
is the brother of colossus has allied
himself with an organization that seeks
the purpose
of bringing down the x-men it's crazy
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob before
if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you